xem tâm sự được cái gì mà cái này bỏ
quay
ờ ờ
mình bình thường hay nghe nhạc kiểu vì
nó có vợ ở nhà cũng à Mà thực ra có
nhiều bài Lạnh hoặc nhưng mà thấy mình
thích ở đây là cái cái bài đăng người ta
đăng ấy người đang một ngày 123 gì đấy
và cái văn của họ khá là hay hợp tâm
trạng Nhưng mà ông nào vào tâm trạng
hiểu tâm trạng Đây không phải tâm trạng
với mỗi ở Yêu đương như họ đang về yêu
được khá nhiều tâm trạng kiểu
về một mối quan hệ nên như nào như nào
cũng phải cả G2
nghĩa mày ông cũng thể đọc phải tham
khảo để tham khảo đây tham khảo với góc
nhìn về một mối quan hệ có thể khá tốt
về video này
Ừ dạo này tôi thấy à Anh ấy nói khá hay
ở đây tôi chẳng có tiền mày không nghe
ở
đó là những người xâm phạm quyền lựa
chọn của người khác hỏi mới đi làm có
một việc xảy ra là
chúng vẫn cứ chân chưa suy nghĩ mãi mà
không biết nên đi hay không để tớ xác
kiến ngày mà sáng ngày hôm sau là sẽ đi
rồi thì hôm nay anh nó bắt đầu xin sếp
làm gì cho anh Off và khi mà ngồi nói
chuyện với sếp của mình sẽ mang rất là
trầm tư trăn trở bò tay bức tao cổ sao
vậy nhỉ cũng khóc theo như vậy luôn hả
thằng cháu sẽ bạn nói là thương ơi là
Lan cảm thấy thật Quá khó để quyết định
bởi vì sáng ngày mai lại mất rồi mà tới
ngày hôm nay em mới báo khẩn cấp tới như
vậy Bây giờ thì quyết định sao đây nếu
mà anh đồng ý em off thì nó chẳng phải
là tao đồng tiền lệ xấu sao có cái gì để
cái xác giờ nói chứ không bao giờ quên
tính toán trước Nếu anh không đồng ý cho
em thì chẳng phải là anh đã không chỉ
người sách còn sao thì anh sẽ Z10 sẽ nó
cũng khóa luôn nó này cũng không biết
làm để trả lời với em đi như thế nào đây
thôi mà anh cứ thốc lên để đi chung với
gia đình của nó bài học mà anh ghi nhớ
hoài trong đầu của mình đó là đừng bao
giờ đẩy người khác vào cái thế mà không
có sự lựa chọn phải không Nói làm cái
chuyện mà nó học quan trọng khẩn cấp cần
phải báo liền ở thời điểm nó mới được
thì không nói rồi nhưng có những cái
việc chúng ta thật Lem tính bắt như
trước thì hãy sắp xếp a
anh này chia sẻ góc nhìn à Cái dạ nhà
bắt mình là người khác để bạn suy nghĩ
đã có để ý tinh ý tưởng người ta chịu
nóng một lần rồi nhưng mình kéo để tính
nhỉ để mình à rút kinh nghiệm
anh cái em kể bài học hay Nhưng tại tôi
không thích địa điểm là là anh này bà
lắm mà video bắn vài từ tiếng Anh trong
đấy thôi tôi hơi bị kỳ thị việc là nói
nửa tiếng Anh ở tiếng Việt - Khi ở đang
dạy học trong mấy ông nhiều lúc rồi tôi
bắt buộc phải dùng tiếng Anh bởi nó từ
chuyện này cũng không tôi sẽ Hạn chế
dùng cậu lạm dụng điều như thế những cái
từ mà
phụ trách hạ tiếng Việt có dùng từ mượn
tiếng Anh hai thứ k002 lắm tôi quan niệm
thế không biết mày không thể nào à
trước thì đã chia sẻ là được chia mục
lục 2 chưa sẽ lại phát
Ý nghĩa Hồi trước ở tội tầng đang thông
báo cho mấy ông người việc à cần mấy ông
kiểu dáng hỗ trợ để mà làm trên mục lục
các bài à Bạn làm rồi thì tất cả là làm
video để mà làm chót để đăng lên các nền
tảng khác ấy thì có một bạn đồng ý rồi
và bạn đấy cũng làm visa đầu tiên khá ấn
tượng với trót đầu tiên tôi nếu mấy ông
lý nhưng gần đây lại khá là bận tôi như
không liên lạc nhắn tin không thấy trả
lời gì mấy ờ
Em hãy cho tôi vẫn sẽ phải cần một hai
bạn nữa để mở cửa cần rồi mà
khi chỉnh sửa cắt ghép từ video
kiểu làm như kiểu bạn hãy 02 kiểu dạng
ghi phụ phụ đề cho video để mà nhà mạng
xã hội khác
cho tôi Công nhận về tôi bạn thật nổi
kiểu ngoài làm việc tôi còn tự nghĩ ý
tưởng này làm so với kết hợp việc rồi
còn chấm bài nữa chấm bài không nghĩ
em dậy gì tiếp theo nữa mệt
Ừ hai mẹ đáy dụ điển hình hôm nay cũng
mệt tôi với đi cả ngày về nhà tôi vẫn cố
dậy
khi dùng thực cố gì cũng đúng đấy bởi vì
mình đam mê hội chưa thực ra đấy nó cũng
mà cũng chẳng có gì ngoài đam mê được
rồi thế
à à
ờ ờ
Ê bà một cái nữa tâm sự chứ sao lại tâm
sự về chia sẻ vui vui và hãy phết có đề
bài của một bạn là mấy ông nhớ hồi học
HTML không ạ bạn để làm cái trang này
Trang bày bài 3 trang mà tôi yêu cầu là
cậu sử dụng chỉ alo để tạo ra kiểu bố
cục của một trang web Thế bạn này làm
thi công rồi đấy khí công ở đây không
phải là
chứ không phải là để mỗi cái như này mà
Tôi thấy buồn cười điểm bấm vào mình cái
này tôi sẽ bấm vào máy ông nhé
à à
Ừ mà mày cái link này Linh thật này Nhảy
đến phim phim mới chiếu phim moi
kịp tay cẩn thận này
à à
thế
em ăn cho new xe mà
anh cũng toàn là hmg không có tía CS nào
nha
Ừ thôi mình đã chỉ dạy hai tầng lầu
thuần mà đâu có xe thì đâu đúng không
anh cũng chịu khó
đầu bắt đầu học HTML Tôi cảm thấy
cũng kiểu dạng mà
anh cũng gọi đời đầu không ạ
anh cũng thấy vui khi mà mấy bạn đấy có
đăng bài tập các thứ thứ hãy niềm vui
nho nhỏ tôi ở những cảnh như thế không ạ
Ừ thôi bây giờ bắt đầu buổi học hôm nay
họp hôm nay thì mình sẽ dạy mày các bạn
về à
Chắc là cái vụ mà hôm trước về Audi cho
là tôi Phải khẳng định khi nào mò được
với tội chưa có thời gian mình mỏi luôn
mà bận chết bây giờ tôi cứ đăng nhập
thẳng luôn á á
à à
đề thi đại tiên Tắt hết ở ngoài đó nha
ờ ờ
anh admin này
Ừ
ok Google ơ được tiền là Việt Nam in
đúng không
em Intex này
à à à chuyển Thái Tổ sang phải thay thôi
mà nhỉ
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ mẹ biết thay thỏ
à à
đề đấy Sao ạ
ở đây được không nhảy vào đây tao xem mà
giờ controller nhà đất
a hard reset mình về nhớ đến nhu rô phi
thích này thằng admin lại bị sai ờ ờ
cho mình đăng nhập xong mình sẽ phải nhớ
sang bên user ừ ừ
nhảy sang lyle Masstel mà không truyền
cái biển hay khổ vào đây nên nó lỗi sẽ
thấy kiểu như này lắm chị ạ Có không Có
được sẽ cho chồng ngay
dưới đây nữa biển thay thôi Có rồi nữa à
sẽ hiểu sang trang trống trống trơn như
thế này thì sao ngoài cái Trang à level
Master này thì các bạn tạm một cái
control welcome thì tốt thôn để biến ăn
mì được ra mình chỉ nhan Minh Trọng được
ra sáng bên này nó trông nó sẽ như này
không ạ trước mình đã làm cái kiểu thôi
hôm trước cũng chưa sửa xe sửa đoạn này
cơ ờ ờ
đề thi cho mình đã làm cái vụ là kiểu
như này rồi đó là kiểu hiển thị ra danh
sách là đây cơ bản thôi
chờ đợi tí đợi gì
trong như nào
thì các bạn thế có rất nhiều người dùng
đúng không ạ Thực ra là mình hả Mình có
thể là mình nên Future kiểu dạng là phi
tơ theo City này tô theo kiểu dạng là
Company này cái kia của anh hệ
ở mấy cái váy cá Exciter nữa sẽ có vài
cái mình sẽ Peter
Ừ để tôi xem nha ồ
xe Tata thuê bổ đấy cũng được nhé mà
muốn thì mình có thể dùng đã ta thấy bồ
đây để mặc sư Tower Hán nhiều trường cho
mày
cách xem password Avatar
filter đi
cái bài phân tích đã thích hồi trước của
mình là
ừ ừ
phân tích
Ừ anh đi hát với bạn ạ
à à
Ok mình phân tích là onme này trang quản
lý thông tin này cho anh quản lý người
dùng này không ạ thì còn lấy người dùng
ở đây bạn chất là mình mình mình phải
quản lý cụ thể quản lý ở cái gì mình sẽ
còn lý là
người đấy là ai Này người đấy chức vụ là
gì không
tổ chức vụ kiểu level là
thì mình sẽ phải Phi tơ trước một vài
cái ở đây trước đã chuyện như thế Mình
mình sẽ Peter ở đây kiểu Tôi nghĩ là sẽ
có khá nhiều Peter ở trên này để mình để
mình chọn tích tích tích tích vào
khi họ sẽ kéo dài
không cần dùng đã Tao thấy bổ trường hợp
này dùng làm thuần cho các bạn xem ở tôi
sẽ Peter hết ở trên này khá nhiều Nitơ đ
dần tất cả ra trước đi anh nhá avatar nó
ngon avatar Tôi nghĩ à thường avatar
trước tên đúng không I know ta mày à
em nhớ có phải ảnh đã bị lỗi anh Thành
là nó lâu thế
cha mẹ ông thấy thời trang đâu ra mà
đang bị lỗi loát lâu Ờ
công nghệ tôi tạm xóa mấy cái á already
Xóa toàn bộ về lal em ở đây đi
chủ nhật này mày phết nhỉ sẽ là update à
khi sex
Where hay đi nhỏ hơn trò chắc đi nó số
này
và danh sách danh sách à
các thành viên này là giảm dân như này
A cho người ngồi đăng ký lên đâu cái
kiểu như này ok chưa tiếp theo nữa đó là
mình thêm kiểu dạng là thì một vài cái
như là kiểu ở
khi sex
khi đôi khi các bạn hãy phân tích cả lại
trước trước khi gã bắt tay vào là chứ
đừng có ngu Mình mình ở kiểu mình đang
vừa làm một nghĩ ra thấy không tốt lắm
Anh sẽ có email ở đây Tôi nghĩ là một lọ
ông tách rõ là thông tin hai ông thể Gộp
chung lại trong ngày nó tên in họ được
chị sẽ là kiểu à chúng dòng như này đây
sẽ là email đúng ạ thì tôi muốn Á có
cách để mà làm vụ này nó mình sẽ ra
anh ở đây này Tại sao đây lại thẻ ra thì
Tôi từng chỉ em mấy ông có phải cho là
được Atlat như thế này sau đó thì nó sẽ
xem mail tôi mày không nhớ nhỉ à
mày ông Hộ trước lau ấy
Ê mèo tu này à
hạn thì nó sẽ cậu lập tức cả gửi mail hộ
tiêu cụ thể cho mấy ông
thì nó sẽ hiểu thế chồng chị mà không
tiếp theo là
chị sẽ có là
vì hồng đúng không Số điện thoại
cho số điện thoại là Phone này
à à
thực hiện ảnh hiện ảnh lớn hơn khi mình
để chuột và avatar như thế này á Tôi
dùng cái hoover run cái tiện ích
showroom
Ê hồi trước của tôi Tôi thích trình Tôi
cũng chém gió là đấy tính năng Bọn em
làm hiệu Duy Mạnh thực ra không hề run
rồi à Ờ phone number đ
Ừ nó kêu này này
Ừ để bấm vào sẽ gọi Hồ Sỹ mãi
đá bóng bán kết nối sang điện thoại gì
đó để mà gọi
ạ
link này nên trang cá nhân có
ấn vào trang cá nhân tôi nghĩa là vẫn sẽ
có mục là để ấn vào xem trang cá nhân cụ
thể nữa Ở đây mình bạn chất là mình bấm
được đi là sự thế thì mình sẽ có thể A
để bấm cụ thể vào xem chi tiết của một
thành viên
sẽ ra r vào đây
ở xã ya router
là trong trường hợp này thì à
à à
Ừ
thế bồ à
thì tôi muốn gọi là chữ use rồi Tôi
không muốn khai báo nhiều
Ừ tôi sẽ báo với cả này à
Em có thấy bồ này không có chấm này
vì đây bạn chất Nó là một mà nếu không
thấy
cho
nên sẽ có là cái là ghét Ở đây mình
truyền ai đi lên đấy à
trò chuyện cùng giơ lên đấy mình sẽ có
dơ lên nha sẽ ra đi thêu này hoặc sâu
Tên nó là sau gì vậy Xem chi tiết
sau này ở đây sẽ chấm Sau ngay được
trong trường hợp này mình sẽ chuyển đổi
lợi ích và sau
đó sẽ hiểu là
ở đây là số nhiều
ở đây công an xuống nhiều mà
ở đội tuyển đầu tiên
ờ ờ
cho nên mày nhé
trước ăn vậy rồi tí như hôm trước và
mình đúng rồi nó phải admin như này nữa
Ừ ok
cho mình thêm amin thôi à
về bản chất là mình sẽ gọi đến cái Hàn
sau để xem cụ thể một người
công nghệ tình sau đã
anh ở đây mình sẽ có rô để phân biệt bọn
mình rô đây là Quyền Quyền xem người gì
đúng không Rồi
Ừ
nếu ở mình chuyển dạ mình hiển thị ra
hiểu
a pizza rô bình thường khi nó sẽ hơi tối
nghĩa sẽ không hiểu
0011 là cái gì không ạ Đấy Bây giờ mình
để hiển thị ở chọn thì mình sẽ tôi sẽ
sang bên này bên là u rô này xong rồi
Như tôi từng bạc mình sẽ có khái niệm là
Ờ Ờ mình sẽ khái niệm là ghét cho tên
của kẻ IQ mình đặt mình sẽ à rau nêm Vậy
mà
nói là tiền Chipu này Đấy rùa bạn chất
là mình sẽ ghi tên goroth Pro như này
đúng không
ở các kiểu trả về rô Nhưng mà mình sẽ
gọi đến zô
ti5 này để mình lấy được mình sẽ lấy ra
hai kỹ thằng này chứ không phải lấy
thằng này sẵn ạ thì nó hôm trước của tôi
nhớ tôi chỉ mấy ông xem có cái hàm là
hàm for value để trả về bản thân nó này
ờ ờ
I get value Truyền Kỳ vào sau ghép vào
lồ này
khi được này mình sẽ à Ơ ơ
a pro i5 này à
Xong rồi Ghét lá luôn nha
à Xong rồi trả về Không tại sợ không vì
hôm trước và nhà Ông thấy là nó trả về
mạc Nhưng mà thưa chỉ có một thằng thằng
đầu tiên ý ấy
A và bên này sửa lại bên này mình sẽ sửa
lại Ạ Zona như thế này à
Chào Việt Nam đúng nhỉ
Ừ để tính Nhật Đợi tí nhá
ô ồ
ừ ừ
tôi ghét đi
đó admin này em heo
a ly cân béo không thể muốn nó viết hoa
mỗi chữ cái đầu giống như hàm Tôi dùng
nó là
đầu tiên để mày ông Huệ ép nó thành nhà
trình tu lau xong Lucy phát thì sẽ ra
kết hoa mũi trước cái đâu nhờ cũng có
nhiều Hàn để nó chỉ viết hoa mỗi chữ cái
đầu thôi thằng ario nó có hỗ trợ cái vụ
hepl đấy mày không xem với vụ Hamster
này sẽ là nó sẽ hiểu với string này cam
yêu này em yêu là sẽ ra viết kiểu kiểu
dạng là kiểu con lạc đà những mấy ông
cùng biết đi ờ ờ có cái hàm tôi nghĩa có
cái Hàn để biết Hà Nội trước cái đầu đấy
có ai nó sẽ viết hoa
ở cái đầu đời kiểu gì thế
chị rõ là có những hàng có sẵn rồi nhưng
vẫn vẫn ghi ở trong này không hiểu lắm
ờ ờ
Ừ Ok Alo Tiếp theo gì nhỉ
ô ô sin
a oxi Soon
ô ồ
Ồ thông tin thông tin này để xem nhé Để
xem nha à
Ừ nó vẫn lại info Thôi cứ nghĩ nó vẫn
lại info
thì mình nên hiển thị cái gì bây giờ
mình là mình được mình sẽ ưu tiên là
mình sẽ hiển thị thêm là
tên của Company này
Anh tên thành phố này
ở vị trí à
à à
báo đầy đủ trường có nên không ạ ý ông
mà sao nghỉ à la la viện ra nên khai báo
đầy đủ chứ
chứ không phải đầy đủ Nói chung một cái
gì không cần truyền vào đấy không khai
báo thôi
Cho tôi xin này cho con gì nhỉ Giới Tính
giới tính thì ra tôi nghĩ là sẽ đẩy
trước kể thằng này
ờ ờ như tôi từng bảo mấy ông cách để máy
in giới tính thì nó sẽ là
đâu nhỉ Tôi sẽ để nó giới tính ở đây đi
Gọi ếch đây là Ờ mình cũng Channel đúng
không
ăn đồ này
sẽ tạo một cái A review lấy giới tính sẽ
ghét Sendo đồ
cho nên ngay vào đây sẽ ra
ăn đồ lạnh Nếu mà đôla ĐT
gọi đến chando à
a = = 0
Ừ thì mình sẽ trả về là bạn nam chẳng ạ
à À mua rồi nó là Male female thôi Kiểu
này được đi
à à
được tiếp theo là City
City ở city tách hãy cột vitamin D như
cột ra của riêng để tí sẽ về sau mình
filter theo những cuộc này nó dễ
chỉ mày Ông về đi xem ship luôn đây mấy
ông thấy có Company đúng không Nếu không
sẽ nghĩ cho rồi cái bảng Company này để
lấy lấy ra cái nêm của nó đúng không nó
không Chúng tôi không làm thế Ở đây
chúng ta sẽ làm như thế nào mình sẽ sẽ
nối mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ khái niệm là
anh thường ở khai báo cái này lại sao
báo trước của cả mấy thằng cha này cơ để
chuyển ship mình sẽ phải báo trước mấy
là ngày
mình sẽ tra ở trên thằng Tài liệu này
nha nó sẽ khái niệm gì ở trên chip như
thế này à
Tao thấy bồ nữa cái bạn này không không
dùng Ờ mình sẽ có
về bản chất là một
ở một công ty có nhiều nhiều người dùng
nhờ một người dùng chỉ thuộc một công ty
one-to-one
Ừ nhưng mà nói là bia lon tu thuộc về sẽ
ngược lại như này
Ừ tôi sẽ Coffee đây
ở đây mình sẽ đội nó là và nó sẽ khai
báo đây kiểu không không có thêm chữ s
đằng sau đó không phân li thường nghe
thôi còn y này ở đây sẽ Company này à
tên cột khóa ngoại là công ty gạch dưới
ID
thì ông ấy để tưởng anh nhé
cho nên có money này sao cho đến nay đi
như thế này
à à trạng chọn nêm trước nhập ăn uống ơi
để hôm trước tôi quên cài cho mấy ông
cái á readyboost 3A
liên hệ cho mình cần biết được mình chạy
câu truy vấn như thế nào để mà mình tối
ưu nó Vân Vân không ạ Có phê này nhá
cho thuê xe cẩu bạn chất là nó sẽ hiển
thị ra kiểu câu truy vấn như thế nào thì
mới ông sẽ hình dung giả sử như thế này
mà Ông thấy là
a Game of non-object
a a đây đây đây nó có cái tình huống ấy
chạy ra sự mới Ông thấy có riêng kệ
trường hợp này cầm bên ly ID đang ở
trống đó là nên xảy ra là gọi đến
Company ở đây không được con mới đi đây
là nôn nên là không khai báo được cậu
không phải vào lúc luôn được non Jack
như thế này tất cả không Khai bao là
kiểu nêm của cái thằng ngu này được thì
ở đây tôi cũng có câu hỏi xử lý với dữ
liệu luôn này thì razzil có cái Hà mà
optional như thế này ông sẽ ghi đúng nửa
ngày cho tôi sẽ không bị cái lỗi em nữa
với trong trường hợp mà công viên I có
đây có miếng có thì ông sẽ gọi được nên
còn không thì họ sẽ không báo lỗi như
cái kiểu Tôi đang bị như này
chị sẽ không lỗi gì nữa anh về không
khéo áo này có cái đi bước 3 rồi nếu
không sẽ thấy câu truy vấn của tôi sẽ
như này cái có truy vấn này ra nó đang
bị lặp đi lặp lại nó là nồi cộng một câu
truy vấn Thực ra sao nghĩa có 15 người
dùng thì lại phải có 15 câu truy vấn nữa
Sang cái bạc Company để lấy được cái nêm
của Company thế không tốt hoặc cách là
cách để mình khắc phục cái điều đấy thì
mình sẽ phải khai báo ở bên A
giờ control à
thì mình sẽ ở đây mình trong trường hợp
này mình sẽ có khái niệm là vít rất gà
mình sẽ kiểu kèm thêm Company khi mình
lấy ra dữ liệu sẽ quýt như này Company
nha à
ở đó tôi Tại sao đây thì mới ông sẽ thấy
câu chỉ vật nó sẽ ra rễ Tôi sẽ chỉ ăn gà
là lấy toàn bộ toàn bộ poster này và lấy
toàn bộ Company ra Where in theo trong
cái danh sách user ở đây thôi tôi sang
trang thứ 2 thì nó sẽ nó sẽ theo phải ai
danh sách ad khác hiểu vợ như thế nhưng
ở lại nó vẫn có hơi bị Hơi bị nhược điểm
một tí đó mới Ông thấy à
Nó vẫn sẽ Rex sao từ Company thì là tôi
không thích như thế nếu mà ông 15 cẩn
thận đấy thì làm chuẩn ấy là để cho nhẹ
thì mới ông sẽ ông sẽ phải xe lách đúng
cái thứ mà ông muốn không hạn chế xây
sao Vì bảng ông có quá như cột nghe
chẳng ạ Đấy thì ông sẽ nói cụ thể ở đây
cũng sẽ lách cụ thể cái gì với user thì
ông sẽ lấy cái gì làm thế tôi thường này
kiểu đi hẳn nhiên này với uzone select
ID nick name lại ở đây đây Thế con với
thằng Company thì làm như nào ông sẽ có
khái niệm là hai chấm như thế này không
gõ tiếp như thế này cho tôi
không không được cách ra đấy như thế này
cách lỗ này và cho Rủ ông ấy mỗi nêm ý
nhưng mà ông gọi phải lấy cái ID nha Tại
sao Vì ai đi này để nối đến cái thằng à
để mà hiểu được là cái idea sẽ nổi
Company Company ID mà nói cho cột khóa
ngoại ông sẽ phải luôn xe Lách huyện Chợ
Lách như này được thôi có ai ông sẽ thấy
nó nhẹ hơn khá nhiều bữa trưa
có thêm thêm mới bạn
Ừ ừ Thực ra là mình có khi mình không có
cái vụ thêm ở đấy đâu Tôi đang cân nhắc
này xem nha
có thêm à
à
Ai Cập nhật lúc nào
em
này cái này còn em nhé Cái này để lấy
được Tôi đang muốn là xóa xóa mềm hàng
ngày giờ Sự Vì sao chậm nó
anh xóa nó
Xin chào cậu thế
anh xóa nó là mình sẽ phải ở toàn Xóa
toàn bộ những cái liên quan đến nó nữa
vì sao vậy chị em về trước hết ở xóa rồi
xóa nó đã ở đây tôi Nghĩa
cái xoăn mềm mại như thế Tôi sẽ
sửa database đi
I am
enter
and
directed
à à
ô tô table
Ô Ô thế bộ đi
đây mình sẽ
có thêm những cột là với Bảo ngu giờ này
em gái mình sẽ có đi thật ấn này à
à à
anh không cần em tôi ở đây mình sẽ còn
luôn này bộ đây rồi mà được phép luôn
anh như này
ô ồ
làm như thế không cần the foe's làm đâu
mặc tĩnh lặng sẽ luôn rồi
Ừ nếu mà không có thì tôi sẽ thêm bạn
này
sẽ có bạn Giờ mình có mạng đi nha Bà Nà
Company Tại sao vì về sau tôi muốn là
giả sữa cái công ty bị báo cáo nhiều quá
Mình có thể xóa toàn bộ công ty đi Xóa
toàn bộ công ty toàn bộ nhân viên ở sẽ
bay tượng như thế Nhiều tiện nóng hình
dung họ
kompany này à
về việc nghỉ à
a fire
ở đây sau mình tố cáo những cái gì nhỉ
em chụp cái xương mất về sau tố cáo vẫn
đi rồi đấy thai có thể tất cả đấy đi tố
cao file không hợp lệ
khi phanh không hợp lệ thì mình có thể
xóa file đi cũng được nhỉ
cách xóa file đi xóa file đi Để tôi
nghĩa xóa thẳng nhưng không phải là xóm
mềm nữa
ở xóm mềm đây là xóa người dùng theo
kiểu là người dùng vi phạm xóa
qua Mason ha ý ông à là liên kết Vừa rồi
con mua đổ không cần phải liên kết qua
khóa ngoại
áo khoác ngoại thử cái để giảm buộc Chắc
còn bản chất cái liên kết qua mua đồ như
vừa rồi Tôi vừa làm đi ship thì chỉ đấy
chỉ đơn giản là dùng cây Trôi của bạn
nghĩa nó không có một sự liên kết để cả
nó không có ràng buộc gì cả nghĩa dữ
liệu sai thì nó không hiển thị ra thôi
nó không toàn bộ gì cả
file file người dùng đăng nhé Mà bị tố
cáo mà mình xóa xóa file luôn Xóa cứng
luôn Không không lưu lại trong database
thì về sau mình không biết được là có
bao nhiêu
anh Vi phạm nào không report cho vẫn còn
Ừ nhưng mà file bay mất rồi ta không
biết được là ạ những ai vi phạm nhiều
Tôi nghĩa là cứ thêm một cột đi tất đi
biết được cụ thể ông nào vi phạm nhiều
trong khoảng thời gian nào đó mình có vụ
tố cáo có lý do cảm
Vì thế tôi sẽ thêm cả trong mạng file đi
cả khuyết tật ấy này không có cột Zed
chất thì ở không biết được tạo lúc nào
đúng không
thu hồi sách Chỉ Cần Thế còn bé lắm nữa
bài đăng
Cha Mẹ 7 đang có bé năng lại có sóng mềm
rồi ok ok
chỉ có ba cái này cần làm
à à
ở đó bây giờ tải lại
ở đâu có khoảng sao mềm
ừ ừ
tội lỗi tôi không có thì mới thêm Nội
Tôi
Ừ nếu mày ông chạy sai thế thì mày ông
vào đây mấy ông chơi trò này về tôi
không có tạo cái down vừa rồi mấy ông
thấy đó tôi không phải tạo cái Dock này
vì thực ra là mình không có khi mình
thêm cái cột như ngày rồi Ít khi mình
xóa cột ốp cột để đi lắm
a cho một vài trường hợp với ông ốp cột
thì đi thôi
ý tưởng sẽ chọn ngay ông sẽ ở và xóa thủ
công trở lại đây à trường kỳ Hữu rồi
trường hợp kiểu tặng là ông à
a Company website I
xe
tải lại trang này giờ có đi tất Ok rồi
xe côn tay Lúc đó sẽ chấm
anh về sau mình có thể có tính năng xóa
ở đây mình không Tôi đang nghĩa là không
có cập nhật cho người dùng cho mình sẽ
có tính năng xóa người dùng Nếu là sự ạ
Đừng xem tố cáo là bị xóa
được ai giống ai Cái amikacin này nó tạo
có cái chữ shopee lễ đó cũng được được
ngay cái nha bằng nhau này
còn gì nhỉ
quên đấy em gái mình sẽ có fit ở trên
đúng không Thế mình thường sẽ vứt vào
trong cái các hết đâu rồi
anh sẽ có thể form này tôi sẽ bắt chước
cái phone của thằng hyper đi
ừ ừ
Phan Minh Thưởng Chắc có rồi và bây giờ
lại không có xe lách góc chân đây select
options
cô gái này
à à
à
đi học đúng nhỉ Không chiều ngang chiều
ngang chiều nhà ngon sau đó thì đít
a-class là for Plus này
ở xã hội như này
xin xỏ đến mình mà không có khó bình
tĩnh còn lấy bồ nó đã lại rất là chưa
vì tội thưởng hệ thích cậu lấy bồ Để như
này
vì vậy giải thích cái mấy ông Tại sao nó
đang lấy bấm vào nó sẽ chọn luôn
em chọn luôn được vào ô
anh alo alo có sức pro
à à
Đợi tin nhắn à
anh sẽ còn biết ở đây là
bay
chiêm bao
à à
Ừ ok này à
thế này
em chọn trước một cái sau đó thì đây sẽ
là ô tất cả sau đó thì tôi sẽ có truyền
à
ở đây tôi sẽ chuyển cái away
Aria pro
ở gần mấy ông có thể
viết thêm chữ s ngày hiểu nó xuống nhiều
được đó là u dơ pro
ti5 mà sợ app Android
chuyển sang bên này như này
anh sữa cho bé uống xem nhé
Đây Bên này mình sẽ Ồ tất cả đúng không
Rồi đây mình sẽ có một cái phối cả đây
anh em mình sẽ có rô này bà ạ
thế này
À mà đây
chị sẽ có
Toàn Zalo à mà
khi họ
admin huracan bài hát Ru Trong Sino
em
mặc định khi mình chọn xong một cái như
này tôi sẽ cho nó tôi bảo tôi sẽ dùng
really đúng không thì tôi sẽ đấy sẽ cho
nó 1 cái là à
a cernex Twitter
chúng tôi để đặt tên nó khi tôi nghe đi
hiểu đó lọc
i10 class này mình sẽ có một cái là
a fuss
anh
chuyền vào trong cái Masstel Đợi tí Đợi
tí e-master mình sẽ có
à à
anh ở đây là ừ ừ
A Z
a cho bạn nào chưa biết cái khái niệm
giữa sách này là khác biệt so với hàng
nêu này Nó là kiểu Cả hai đều truyền dữ
liệu vào nhưng một cái là ông put là ông
tức là ông đầy thêm dữ liệu vào trong
cái trong cái xe này còn con tên này à
con sách trên này nó sẽ ghi đè lên toàn
bộ những cái thằng mà có trong cái này
ví dụ là sự là ông
Hiện tại tôi đang kế thừa 11 rất là tôi
cái thẳng với thằng Masters như là sự có
một khác kế thừa thằng cái file crack
này cho tôi cũng gọi đến 20 phút nữa
hoặc là tôi bút mấy lần như thế này thì
đã sẽ truyền thêm dữ liệu vào trong
thằng thằng này nó khác với thằng này
thằng này sẽ trên này chỉ gọi một lần
thôi nhiều người cứ dùng mà như này
thẳng luôn thay vì dùng hàm dụng cái
sách này Thực ra nó sai
tủ lạnh
à à
ở đoạn này tự nhiên tôi muốn cốt bằng
sau tay tách quá gj mà cốt so với Tech
đoạn này trong đẹp Sufat sao người tốt à
à mà phải chưa
108 được cái
anh không đây mai đi này
nó sau đó mình sẽ có
class
snacks Nitơ đ
à à
Ông Trùm ma ở trên là khi thay đổi
em đi thay đổi thì bản chất là mình sẽ
chạy đến phòng Trinh
thế này à
Ừ thôi tôi biết được có nhiều bạn dùng
cái kia về sao tôi biết được Lý do là
thằng Jackson nó khác hàng xách ngào chứ
hồi trước tôi mới được dùng leo Tôi chỉ
biết tách thôi
anh em khó chịu nha Đợi đi em tờ cái này
sinh này nữa à
thì kệ
Anh vẫn chấp nhận này có lại không không
không hiển thị nến khó chịu nữa thế là
được
khi là cái này thay đổi thì mình sẽ cầm
là gì ở đây tôi vẫn muốn Peter Thế là
tôi sẽ đẩy lên thanh địa chỉ là mình sẽ
ở shopee cái format semaphore này
Anh ở truyền thêm cái gì đó nghe được
a coma phòng đây tôi sẽ tên là for
Twitter được ai đi à
ông Tom Peter này
như này
Ừ
rồi Tại lại cho anh nhé
anh
ấn vào này nó sẽ rô bằng không này A lô
bằng mấy này nghe chẳng hạn đúng không
Thi Khi mà thay đổi do như thế này thì
mình sẽ phải lấy lấy cái rồi về như này
thì mình sẽ
a where
A lô
bằng nhưng với điều kiện phải quan trọng
là với điều kiện là mình có có chuyển
lên hay địa chỉ như thế này thì mình mới
queo cái đấy thì ở đây nó sẽ có khái
niệm một là một một trong hai cách Nếu
không có thể dùng nó như thế này một là
ông không được phép gọi cái này sớm vậy
gọi này ông ấy sư dữ liệu đã mất rồi ông
sẽ viết như thế này ông sẽ
xoạc hay thôi tôi sẽ thử viết hai cách
để mấy ông thấy nó cách nào nó ổn hơn
nhé
Ừ ông
nha
Ừ
ông sẽ phải khai báo nó quay đi như thế
này tức là đây câu truy vấn suy vần đang
truy vấn dự trữ Ông chưa lấy cái dữ liệu
kết quả cuối ông chưa gọi đến hay lấy
kết quả cuối ông sẽ ít web như này à Lấy
cái đúng 0h pro này là nếu có thì ông sẽ
có As I wear thêm như này lại và Rô
Zalo này Đấy nếu có thì ông que như thế
nay ok chưa Đấy sau đó thì đến cuối ông
sẽ có data bằng free
ở đây này
A technique nó khá mất công rửa thế này
tôi dùng từ mất công hiện nó sẽ là ngày
Ông thấy là nó sẽ xử lý nó khá là giường
giả đấy có nghĩa dâm giả
thì tại sao bạn này thì ra có cái lợi
điểm và ông sẽ luôn kiểm tra các chữ số
tiếp theo như thế này nó ngoại Cái thứ
hai mà tôi thường hay làm trong nó đẻ
trong muốn đẹp hơn tí cho nó sẽ bị chậm
hơn tôi sẽ giải thích cả sao chọn hơn
đấy nha
em mệt với trong trường hợp này không
thấy à Có bao nhiêu cái J quét thì ông
sẽ bảo bấy nhiêu kiểu ngày sữa Tí mình
Peter ba cái thì sẽ có 3 gái hiểu ngay
đúng không ạ Đấy
ở khoảng cách thứ hai tôi là nó sẽ như
thế này
Ừ Tôi muốn biết hết vợ trong một cái này
tôi sẽ có khái niệm là que hát thế này
không không phải quay hát when là khi
khi mà cái đúng giống hai cái ít thôi nó
bạn chất nó giống hệt ít khi Cái này
đúng nhá thì mình sẽ gọi đến Hàm phong
trần như thế này
bảo đôla Phi số 1 ở kiện nếu muốn gửi
Peter này nhá trong cái á quen em phải
ghi tên về là mình sẽ copy ở đoạn này
đương nhiên cái doris ở trong này một là
ông phải dùng ưu như này không mới dung
được cái doris à Anh ở trong cái này ở
đây đó là quy chứ
anh đi Tắt đài đôla quyquỳnh A2 là thực
Hà ông có thể viết tắt hơn Thôi anh dậy
mày ông nó hơi bị nâng cao một tí nếu
không thì cứ tắt hơn họ sẽ biết cái ngay
cho tôi cái nhanh gọn không gọi Quét
ngay bạn thậm chưa Ông gọi quét nhau
không cần khai báo này luôn Xóa này bị
được này
nhờ thôi thấy hơi lười quá đấy nha đầu
kia kiểm tra nếu có nếu có đúng không ạ
thì ông sẽ gọi như này ok chưa
Không biết được mấy ông ở đây có ông đã
biết được cái này không biết phá tắt
không ạ lại thì viết như này nó trông nó
đẹp trong một đẹp thôi Nhưng mà cái này
đã chậm hơn Tại sao nó lại chậm hơn bởi
vì mỗi khi ông gọi Ông gọi Quen như thế
này kia bạn chất nó sẽ ít theo nhỉ Nhưng
nó sẽ khởi tạo lại cái thằng Tít một lần
nữa nên là nó sẽ chậm hơn so với việc là
là không Khởi Tại mấy thằng nào cả mà
chị em dạy thêm những điều kiện này đấy
Ừ Ok chưa
Ừ dạo này không biết nãy giờ mới ông có
nghe không à Nãy giờ còn chưa chia sẻ
link cơ nhớ lớp trưởng lại mất tích rồi
có ai đó
chia sẻ link cho link Google Maps cho
các bạn
à à
Anh tôn mới nâng cấp à
Ừ Tôi muốn nâng cấp RAM của máy đến tận
32GB bây giờ mấy ông vào máy tôi thoải
mái không sợ bị lag lắm như hồi trước
hồi trước kiểu vào rất hạn chế đồ treo
luôn
ạ Bây giờ thì da mình 32 GB thoải mái
ở lớp trưởng mà em mất tích rồi nên là
ông nào tạo Linh cô mít rồi chia sẻ cho
các bạn để các bạn xem cốt cho rõ hơn
nhé á
à à Ừ ok đấy thì vừa rồi tôi mới lọc lọc
theo kiểu này mày không thấy à
có điều application nhá À với điều kiện
mình vẫn phải truyền
ở đội to một tí
A lô này
khi sex
diễn biến của thằng áo Tự nhiên nói quy
ước và kiểu viết theo kiểu giảm dụng
ngay không không biết cách dưới hơi khó
chịu được đấy thôi kệ ờ
em nhảy sang bên này
thì mình sẽ có ít
- play news đúng
Ừ thì mình sẽ tập
ở đây đợi tí nha
à à
the values Băng Băng
em mới setup rồi thì mình sẽ nick này em
ít ít
Ừ đợi tí đợi tí nhá
ở Zalo này không à
Gà
12 giờ bằng thôi đó Ok chưa
em giả sử khi em mới vào không có gì nhé
ra
cái đoạn này hơi ấm nhỉ Đợi tí
các bạn Thằng này nó là nun
Dạ cái admin của mình là luôn nhá Nhưng
mà cái thằng à admin của mình nó là
không hay dấu bằng đây ở lại hơi sai thì
ở Tí tôi sẽ Ép kiểu thằng này là hai
triệu indie
Em hãy so sánh cho chuẩn đi
kiểu thành kiểu in ở lại say đợi tí thế
tôi sẽ phải mở đây kiểu chính đi à
xe tải ok rồi nha
chú chó này
anh đùa này đúng không
mẹ nó cho rồi Tại sao vừa tôi khai báo
mất công thế phải rõ toàn thằng này
truyền về khi mà lấy chân hai mẹ chị về
nó sẽ luôn là nhìn mấy ông tưởng là số
như thời gian nó Ép kiểu lại biến thành
chữ
nó hơi khó Còn nếu không mấy ông ép nó
hình số luôn ở đây sẽ phải là
à Tôi nhớ không lầm là nó sẽ phải như
thế này
à à
như thế e-request lại nha
khi các kiểu nó thành số đợi được rồi
thì định thì được tính nha à
số giờ thử xem đã
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
mọi người có khai báo nó là
em Linh thì có nhớ hay bảo được
ở con số thì tôi chưa thấy bao giờ
ừ ừ
I I I put này input mà
a kuaz
thấy có bạn biết không
I only access hát
Ừ nó còn lấy cả season về cơ mà
hồi nãy nhờ Không không lấy à in rồi à
không có Không ạ
Ở Nếu Thế chị có ép kiểu cũng như vừa
rồi Thôi tao xin lỗi
sẽ hiểu ngay thôi sẽ Ép kiểu string ngày
chiến thắng ngày số rồi anh sẽ kiểu ngay
Ocean Nếu Hồng mì ông muốn lọc theo
coalition tôi đang nghĩ là tôi sẽ lọc
theo à
ờ ờ
À đầy thiếu này ở đây Cái này cái gì
không có nhà không có đi này
tôi sẽ lọc heo City bảo cầm Pony đấy
mình sẽ có thêm một cái nữa đây đi
- Plus đây đúng không nghỉ ngơi sẽ có là
City này
City ở đây thì nó hơi bị oái Ăn một tí
đó là mình sẽ cần là lấy toàn bộ tất cả
City
xe tải
Wechat à
A3
em
gái mưa chap 3
lỗi tội lỗi tôi I
à à
ở đó mà chụp xấu vãi à
mà mong ước đây
không cần không cần biết vậy ạ
à à
he he lừa rồi cho muốn xấu thế
I like có thử ngay trong xấu thế
chợ hoa tội dùng cái kiểu nghe vậy à
Ê bà lại hồi bé cho năm sinh to không
em không có hiểu
xe lửa vậy
ở lại viện hết ngày mất
Ừ thôi cứ để cho nó trong cái đít đi Chỗ
đào hoa
à à
không có cái class này nó còn bị đẩy vào
ạ
Ừ Ừ trông chẳng khác biệt mấy OK đây Tôi
muốn toàn bộ Citizen sự là sự mấy ông
muốn có lọc theo City ở đây thì ở ôi cần
lấy toàn bộ tất cả City có thể của thằng
ngu dơ sau đó hiển thị liệt kê trong cái
salad of tenai Để mình chọn nó nhanh
không ạ thì khi mấy ông sẽ phải có một
câu truy vấn riêng ở đây tôi sẽ có là
City ngay em ạ
sau đó thì ozo này
mình sẽ đưa rít mua đồ thế này
Khi mà mình sẽ cần lấy toàn bộ City thôi
nóng lạnh thì đây tôi sẽ có khái niệm là
lấy toàn bộ City và lập trùng thì mình
sẽ có là salad distant sẽ là snack à
a City này à
ở Sao Đỏ thì distance tập trung
rất hay sau đó thì mình sẽ ghét để lấy
toàn bộ danh sách kể về chuyện ngay
các câu truy vấn nó sẽ như sau khi tôi
cho mày không xem nhé
À môi cái này nó bị lỗi 1 điểm nó hơi
khó chịu một tí
ở đó là khi mà ông sử dụng mấy câu truy
vấn như này trên này rồi thì khi ông
khai báo lại ông sử dụng đúng cái biến
này nó đôi khi nó sẽ xe Cái lỗi là nó
hiểu là ông vẫn đang ghi đè lên cái
thằng trên cái cách tốt ở đây của mấy
ông Địa ông sẽ thương ngày ông ghi thêm
à Nãy nucleare cho tôi như này chưa Nó
câu truy vấn mới hoàn toàn
dự báo này Kệ đi
nó sẽ không bị lỗi
Âm Nhạc
Ừ địt
ở chỗ sửa heo
phải nuclôn nuclôn rồi
thì giờ đây nó sẽ câu chuyện như thế này
ông xe máy sẽ là đầu tiên là đến đến mẹ
trả về hết này lấy ra 15 thằng này lấy
toàn bộ Company này và lấy toàn bộ
Company
ICT ở đây để ăn gì mình có cái sim danh
sách City ở Bình sẽ đồ ở trong đây thôi
The Flu không cần nữa vì hai thằng đi
nhau sẽ City này
ở tại mà
à à
chú chạy này
đợi tí có gì đó Sai sai đấy
à à
à quên quên quên quên quên quên
anh nghe đang bị lỗi bởi vì nếu mà ông
để kỹ nó đang in ra khi vào lấy cái khi
lấy dữ liệu cái City này ạ
Ừ nếu sẽ nghĩ là chỉ lấy mỗi cuộc City
thì đúng đấy Chị Mỗi cô Citi cho nó sẽ
I
tuesday mày không xem nha à
Ghê quá Ghê quá
ra mình không không có nhiều City này
đâu Đâu có tạm Limit nó đi cho nó nhẹ
bớt nhá Tôi sẽ Limit 10 đi à
đây nó vẫn bị cái trường hợp là dữ liệu
cho mình mình chỉ muốn lấy giá trị ở
thôi Mẹ không muốn lấy cái á 01 lấy cái
Ừ cái cuộc City làm gì đó rõ ràng là
mình chỉ cần lấy giá trị và đúng không
ánh toàn bộ giá trị trả ra thôi nghĩ
nhiều làm gì giờ đây ông sẽ có hàm
phthalate thẳng nhưng Air Blade ngay
thôi lag
gọi đến city a tôi như thế này ạ
Ừ chị ông xóa sử select này nó như nhau
ở nhà ông sẽ thấy à nó sẽ trả ra được
đúng Chỉ có mỗi đi xóa luôn là cô City
này cho miệng rất tiện đây à
khi mở kẹp blog này rất là hay ông gọi
con lắc ngay nó cũng sẽ hiểu là select
luôn cột đấy Mỗi cột đầy thôi tiên ông
rất nhiều hàm dưới dị nếu mà ông ông làm
là Lara uống sẽ biết có rất nhiều hà
muốn dị rồi nhỉ
Ok chưa để chọn một cái gì đó thì nó sẽ
nắp Thôi đợi tí nha Bây giờ đổi toàn bộ
Cái này Thành city này
em chọn một cái này ở đây tôi sẽ có một
cái option như like trên cô vẫn là lấy
tất cả lúc đầu lời tất cả
như thế này Ok chưa
Em học cái
Chú Đại Dũng chưa nên thành địa chỉ cái
này không ạ thì bạn chất là mình sẽ lại
lấy nó về là tương tự sau này bật trước
hỏi một tí
ờ ờ
Ê bà với lại thế City
a City II
ở bên này
trà sữa này city
không cần phải ép kiểu ngày nữa
em có một thằng chồng thôi
em không có thằng nào đấy
sợ không có thằng nào ở đây rồi vẫn hiển
thị ra nhỉ ảo vãi
a City ở đâu ra vậy nhỉ ơi
Vì Sao Thế nghỉ đi
em có một thằng nào đó ở đây chứ nhỉ
rô ở như thế này này nó không ra
khi gà gáy City này phải lọc theo cả cá
rô này nữa mới đúng nếu là ông muốn lọc
theo nhiều nhưng mà Thôi kệ mình làm đơn
giản thôi
cô đơn giản tuổi Mão mạng bị phức tạp ăn
gì
này thì nó xảy ra này đó thay amin chỉ
thế nó như thế này ra ok chưa Nếu mua
xóa đi thì một là con út ở đây nuclear
bạn chắc nút clear này hồi trước tôi
từng xem một là bản chất nó là thẻ ra
thì quay trở lại cái trang chủ ấy thôi
sự Xóa toàn bộ những cái á sau cái này
đi sẽ clear hết Xóa hết
xanh
như thế mình lại là chia trường hợp vào
rồi đi
em có nghỉ
Ừ đợi tí Thế thì à
ừ ừ có thì tôi làm về cách này đi làm
cách này nhìn web nữa trong nó hơi lằng
nhằng tất cả tôi sẽ làm việc kiểu như
này đi vậy mất công việc
khi nhắm mắt có
rô này e này
nếu có
Anh
không muốn kiểm tra có thôi I
Ừ miễn là khác cái này
tử vi quét nhiệt đồ
khác ngoại ô ô
Ừ nếu mà lấy thằng này
ô ô như này
để lên hai địa chỉ Ô Cửa này đâu thường
là nó sẽ là xóa cái này khỏi Thành địa
chỉ đấy nó không truyền anh địa chỉ như
hai đâu ạ
bạn bè đi cho mấy ông dễ hiểu nếu mà có
nghe chị trả về nè
ở các loại ghét mà
à À cái này claw quên à
à à
thế này
Ừ thì đợi tí nha Đợi tao một tí
Ừ tôi sẽ có
khi
Quét nét pro ngay
à à
a City đóng
Ừ nếu hết hàng ngày
thái khác như này
Ừ thì sẽ quay theo thằng ai Ok này lại
bắt chước tương tự với cái thằng City
luôn nghe xong à
chó tiện mẹ nó đỡ khai báo nhiều gọi
nhiều đến hành vi quét thì vợ không hay
à à
width width này
ô ô này Ra hết ok đấy
a tiếp theo một cái khó hơn đó là tôi và
tôi thử Peter theo thằng City là thằng
Company như thế nào
những bài thơ con bên đi nhé
nhé á
a Company này
ở đầu tiên mình cần lấy toàn bộ có
Company ra để mà fit ở đây á ông ạ Như
vậy hiển thị ra như này có thể hiển thị
ra kiểu Dạ City được mình lấy toàn bộ
Company ra thì mình sẽ có
a company
à à
a z ngày để toàn bộ ra
Ẩm Thực ra là mình
tôi nghĩ là Company mình không có trùng
đâu
em không có chung gì cả bà mình sẽ
cái tên là gì nhỉ à
ở phố vị luôn
tiếp theo là mình sẽ chị lấy mỗi
trường ID và
Có ai đi vào nêm thôi Một là ông sẽ kiểu
ông ghi cậu sẽ lách cho đào hoa
cho đẹp chúng đẹp bạn nha mùa là ông ghi
trong select cho đàng hoàng hiệu snack
thế này đúng không ạ Ai đi vậy nêm này
đem một cách ghi nhá không thể ghi Cách
thứ hai của ông sẽ là cái gì ở trong
hoặc vuông như thế này đấy để cái thứ
hai ông ghi này
à à
Ừ Ông không ghi blog giống như còn lại
tôi làm được lắp chị lắc được một cột ở
nhé không lecter cô đấy Cách thứ 3 ghi
chăm chỉ yêu một người hơi nóng phải ghi
thẳng ở trong két nghe được xóa sự mấy
cái đấy
nó vẫn đều kết quả đều sẽ lách như thế
nhưng dị thằng level này nó cài Cả phát
triển để lừa cho người dùng theo nhiều
cách riêng
cho mấy ông xem thử câu truy vấn nhé
lên chưa
chạy hàm két cho ông chuyên hóa mạnh
ngay ông sart20 đấy à
Ừ hi Company ở đây tôi sẽ báo Công an đi
bên này
a Company này
Ừ
ok vào đây sẽ select thật Company nhưng
Đợi đã
a Company tiếng Anh à
em ở Tiền Là Có Tất cả Không ạ ra ngay À
đây đội lỗi tội lỗi thôi để sẽ phải là
Hoàng cam any idea
anh ở đây sẽ là nêm I
có va lu vì rõ ràng là ở trên này trong
trường hợp này chứ Ờ bạn chất cái hiển
thị ra cũng chính là value nè Tôi không
cần phải khai và Peru nữa Như trong
trường hợp này nó khác cái hiển thị ra
là cái nêm và cái và lưu lại cái đi nó
sẽ gần ngay
A9 lên nha thấy hiệu Lấy toàn bộ những
cái nuôi dùng Anh
Anh ở Company là chín lúa ạ
bây giờ làm nó ở xử lý các đoạn này đây
hôm nay Company đây đúng không
thế objective companies
nếu mà không trống
Ừ nếu không phải là tất cả
em vừa rồi có tất cả không nhỉ
ạ Bây giờ có tất cả nếu không phải tất
cả Không ạ thì mình sẽ
anh ở đây nó sẽ có khái niệm là ông thầy
có quýt như này đến gọi địch Company à
VSIP để mà lấy toàn bộ dữ liệu của Rin
ship đấy và cũng sẽ có khái niệm que hát
nè nữa cũng sẽ gọi đến thằng nguy xin
chip này
anh ở đây ông sẽ có khái niệm là song
phương trình này Uyên trở lại with ơn
ngay quy where
có ngày ai đi mà ông sẽ truyền cái xây
tật Company này vào đây này
chị sẽ tất Company I
cho tôi ta lại cho anh nhé Bây giờ chọn
trí đúng không
Ừ đợi tí đợi tí truyền xây tất Company
62 luôn
in a mấy ông xe
Ê bà xã estate Company này
tại trai
thi thoảng mấy ông bị lỗi này do bị quá
tải quá thì ông thì loa này cái này được
nhé
ô ồ
a Where is it là kiểm tra liệu bắt buộc
phải tồn tại ở trong cái bảng Company
were gái ide-ide Company này Long 9 tại
ra tiện này xin ông ạ
cái Hãy so sánh hai bằng nhau nhé để cho
ai đi bằng chị nữa da xịn à
anh nghe đoạn này đúng rồi đoạn này chỉ
có ra những cái người ở trong Company để
thôi Nếu không thấy không
Ừ kệ sách tập Company nhớ đang lỗi ra
được Hình như là do là tôi dùng 3G băng
ID là số Cái này như thế xong chiều nói
chuyện hay hai đầu bằng thôi
hoa quả ép kiểu nhưng tôi vừa nãy nói
thì sẽ Ép kiểu string thì mình hoàn toàn
bao giờ ba đưa tại sao Vì sẽ thật
Company này có thể là
chỉ có thể là trống đầu có thể chống
những ai không có không có
em rồi sẽ không bị lỗi gì cả Còn nếu mà
ông Xóa ID và ông để nó hay chỗ băng
đâu nó sẽ hiểu
3000 sao coi này đi này thừa nó
Có ai đi Ở không ở đường số 0 công nghệ
ép Kiểu cái thằng này thành tựu In cũng
được tùy với ông lại ông thể ép kiểu Đây
kiểu ý được anh ạ
Đà Nẵng
Ừ ok chưa nó
chắc là tôi cũng hơi chậm Hôm nay tôi
đang hơi mệt mẹ trầm theo hi vọng mấy
ông nãy đời hiểu tôi nói gì không ạ ngôi
sao bác gì nó không nhỉ
tôi chỉ cho mấy hôm qua về cách chữ tơ
này ship các thứ thứ Thực ra thì với
người dùng thì ạ với người dùng này thì
tôi nghĩa thêm tính năng là xóa thôi tôi
sẽ làm nốt tính năng xóa chứ cũng không
có update không có thêm người dùng mới
có nghĩa là không có thêm mà người dùng
sẽ tự đăng ký ở vụ này
Ừ thôi nghĩa người dùng sẽ tự đăng ký
à à
mới hiển thị cái thứ hai
a a
Em không hiểu ý bạn lắm nghĩa là
em nghĩ như nào nhỉ
như thế này nhé
mới đề xuất cái à Thì cái đấy Bạn sẽ là
mình sẽ dùng ra Suite được bắt thôi
Sự Như Ý bạn là như thế
cần liên quan cái này thì chỉ đỏ giống
như về sau nếu mà tôi dậy mấy ông về cái
bên A quản lý trường học ấy thì phải
chọn khóa rồi từ chọn khóa rồi chọn lớp
ý thì tôi sẽ dạy miếu mày được cái vụ
đấy
à Còn bây giờ thì có bạn thì nói chung
là nó sẽ giúp da Speed kiểm tra thế
thị ra hết đã thông ạ
à vì tiếp nhỉ đúng nó sẽ chỉ mấy ông nói
cái Xóa nhá Xóa thư gan nó khá dễ thành
anh chị mấy ông bây giờ sửa Delete đấy ạ
chất à như tôi thằng Bảo thì thằng nào
Dell với thằng ezio thì nó sẽ luôn nằm
trong cái phone chứ không phải thể A với
bấm xóa cái gì đó nữa
mình sẽ có bước Tân ở đây nó sẽ là
Delete này à
ốp lát đá
a Battle HD đi chơi ở Xóa
hôm
nay mình sẽ là
em làm Delete
để xóa mềm mà khỏi xóa cứng Ông còn hệ
đặt tên là stop Delete hoặc là Block
cũng được không sao Mình đây sẽ ở chân
sẽ nhảy đến
router là
admin này có Zip thấy bồ này không thấy
bộ thằng luôn
ít trôi
theo theo thằng nó sẽ nào thế
A và mới thức sẽ post chị sẽ có cfrf này
bà
sơ mi hót
chị đã Delete
này ok chưa ạ
Xe ô tô này là Bitcoin
sau đó bấm vào thì sẽ xóa nhưng mà bây
giờ bấm và xóa thì
ô tô bảo nó sẽ xóm mình ạ khai báo một
hàm ý cho nhé
à à
dozer này mình sẽ lấy được sẽ là u dơ
bà cụ dầu ngày
Khi mà mình sẽ gọi đến u dơ Delete ngay
thẳng luôn Nếu mà delete như này sẽ đó
mềm
Ừ thế nào mấy ông sẽ khai báo ở đây cho
tôi cũng sẽ khai báo
trong thằng ngu rô này nó cũng sẽ khai
bảo thêm là h shop Delete cái kiểu như
thế
ở đây phải báo sắp Delete rồi nhỉ
ở shop
Delete
Viettel này đấy
ở
shopee Elite Model này
gì đấy
ờ ờ đúng nhỉ
Ê mày ông sẽ yêu cái sót Delete là được
nghe xong
đi mua đồ shop Delete về chưa có khi nó
sẽ xóa mềm Trông thế thôi rồi điện chạy
thử mấy ông nhé
ở tại lại trai mà không
anh Linh không được ở bấm đây
cho
1280 đó ạ người ông xem
Ừ tôi sẽ Peter IDM
Ơ cái thằng cái thằng à 2 lít này có cái
hai điểm à nếu không sẽ học được như này
ra tiền này
Có
ai đi bằng
cho 1280
à mà nó sẽ lưu lại hộ ông kia đã lọc như
thế nào chưa xóa này đỗ rồi
khi tháo mồi gọi Delete thì chưa lỗi còn
đi chơi à đi nghỉ đi đấy đi đấy
anh hay gọi đến Perry ở đây nó là hiệu
là
ở quê Doodle chứ không phải là lực quân
nhỉ
ừ ừ tôi nghĩa gọi quay có nhà không ổn
I delete
chờ đợi tí nha Đợi tí nhá
the fire When Delete các từ thứ đàng
hoàng Ngai Vàng
ý nghĩa chữ xóa ngay đâu
em vẫn còn mà ờ
Chị Thơ Nghĩa Đô Rio de ở đây không
nghĩa lý do I
em ở xa mà nghỉ không lấy ra được
em không lấy ra được cái gì đó thì phải
Ừ ngày mới chuẩn thế nhỉ
truyền ở trong này chuyển ở đây nè
ở ngoài xuống nhiều
xóa mềm tức làm chỉ ở Mình lưu lại là nó
đã bị xóa trong cột như này chứ không
phải là xóa cứng ở Sẽ Xóa hẳn hỏi để đã
ra đây mình sẽ không biết là thằng ấy
từng tồn tại nếu mà làm như thế nó hoàn
toàn để đăng ký lại vào trang web của
mình có sẵn mềm như này thì mình sẽ
không cho nón kì nữa kiểu như thế
ừ ừ
a terminal Tôi đang dùng á là cái
khi con cmd
hình ảnh
Commander mình đô
đọc nó như thế
I walk Delete không Tôi nhớ đi lấy bình
thường mà
Ừ anh chị gọi Delete bình thường này
thôi
sản phẩm điểm sao nhỉ
à à
mạng nữa
luôn ạ Vẫn chưa
ga nó không đi tên thì bị glitter là Chu
mà nhỉ
- rethink telephone in
ờ ờ anh không có vấn đề gì đây cả không
xóa đâu nhỉ
Ừ không thì thôi không chơi trò ai đi
chơi cái cho kiểu phức tạp ngay vài đi
rồi đây mình sẽ có zip
mua đồ đi choy à
xem sáng được không
không gọi được hàm Bitcoin thằng đi cho
mấy thằng xóa xóa theo tượng nó nó sẽ
khởi tạo lại đối tượng
Ừ nó xóa thẳng không không kiểu dạng là
nếu gọi Delete như này thì ông sẽ xóa
cứng này này cả nghe này
Ừ ông sẽ xóa thẳng đến cái Hà Delete
trông không nghĩa xóa cứng ông không gọi
đến đi tất đâu em ạ nên tôi mới bảo đi
cho đi cho để đăng nhà ông gọi đến thằng
quay cả ngày thì nó không được
xe bọc ly như thế này nói xấu
em chửi thường là nó không quay đi ngay
đâu
Anh bình thường + truyền nên uzair này
được nghỉ với lại bình thường truyền lên
Xóa Nguyên thưởng từ hôm sau mình sẽ
điều hướng quay trở lại
chị sẽ suy tôn Ridielac
Thế bác em có trở lại nha à
khi bấm máy này
Nói chung là tôi đang thảm sát những cái
thành viên ở trong cái xin cái Company
này Ừ
Ok chưa
Quân Nếu hạn chế theo kiểu quay video
cái quần được A nó bị nó bị chậm hơn mà
nó khởi tạo lại đối tượng nhưng về sau
mày không bắt được sự kiện nếu không sẽ
bắt được sự kiện ví dụ Giả sử bây giờ
bắt sự kiện nếu là sự Xóa người dùng như
này tôi sẽ xóa toàn bộ những cái bài
đăng toàn bộ đi cái file của người dùng
với đi không ạ Còn nếu mà ông làm việc ở
Delete thì ông lại phải xóa thủ công
không phải bắt sự kiện thủ công nghĩa
trong trường hợp này ông lại phải
khi khai báo thủ công các thứ còn về sau
tôi chỉ dẫn khai báo ấy ạ với trường hợp
là đây nó có cách ông xem thẳng luôn đấy
xem cái cấu trúc cốt của nó này
thì nó sẽ có khái niệm vừa rồi nó là
file này
thế thôi nhỉ
Ừ đi lại rảnh thế thôi
có ai nó sẽ làm fire mua đồ Y Vân Đấy
đấy là kiểu khai báo
gọi đến cái sự kiện là đĩa tinh là đang
xóa một cái gì đó để xóa những cái thằng
tương tự chẳng hạn Vân
ở
lớp tiện mà ngon để xóa những thằng kiểu
kiểu khác cho thương thế
em à đương nhiên làm con phải có cái thứ
thứ đồng hoa đây là với quyền Admin rồi
ta nó cũng phun Quyền
thấy bồ nói chung là B tăng hai bộ dạy
không mấy ông cho vui thôi rồi cả dự án
Bây giờ người lại ít dùng ra thì bố lắm
khi người ta sẽ làm anh cần ngày thôi
chuyện này Thành địa chỉ như hai các thứ
thứ hai bộ thì nó cũng có cái tiện nó sẽ
xuất thống xuất file hay cái gì đó
Ừ nhưng mà Ngoài ra thì nó cũng có cái
Nặng cũng khó chịu riêng ví dụ là những
cái
Ừ cái này thì ra là có thể là ông độ dữ
liệu về ông có thể à Dùng api để làm ipi
cũng đã thấy bồ nó cả nó chỉ làm được ra
tao thấy bồ rồi nó không làm biến khác
Ừ ok buổi hôm nay chắc là tôi định chị
làm qua với bên trang này Nhìn có vẻ ít
nãy đồ tội đang làm hơi chi tiết một tí
để mà nhảy xa các tính năng sau sẽ dễ để
mà copy hôn sẽ làm tính năng
Khi bữa nay làm quản lý người dùng là
ngon Hôm sau tôi dậy mày ông bị đăng
file đấy Xong rồi đăng bài đăng có sự
thứ cái có những tương đồ đấy Mỗi một
buổi là xong một tình anh chị sẽ khá
nhanh hơn mấy cái sau sẽ phá ngay đâu ạ
ờ ờ
ông cũng phải cập nhật lại cái link ít
nhá Bởi vì tôi may rồi Lại bắt đầu chấm
tiếp đấy Tối nay tôi tí rồi sẽ chấm bài
tiếp mấy ông có vài nhóm đang thiếu tài
liệu trên get quá bổ sung dần nhé
Khi
bữa mày thế này thôi OK Chào mấy ông nhỉ